Mon nom est Lovegrove. Je connais uniquement neuf Lovegroves,
deux d'entre eux étant mes parents.
Ils sont cousins germains, et vous savez ce qui arrive quand, vous savez --
il y a donc un côté extrêmement bizarroïde chez moi,
contre lequel je lutte tout le temps. Donc, pour y arriver aujourd'hui,
je me suis en quelque sorte limité avec un exposé de 18 minutes.
Je me suis retenu de faire pipi.
J'ai pensé que, peut-être, si je retenais assez longtemps,
ça me guiderait à travers les 18 minutes.
(Rires)
Très bien. On m'appelle Capitaine Organique,
c'est une position philosophique et une position esthétique.
Mais aujourd'hui, ce dont je voudrais vous parler, c'est de l'amour de la forme
et comment la forme peut toucher l'âme et les émotions des gens.
Il n'y a pas très longtemps, quelques milliers d'années seulement,
nous vivions dans des grottes,
je ne pense pas que nous ayons perdu ce système de codage.
Nous réagissons tellement bien à la forme,
mais je suis intéressé par la création d'une forme intelligente.
Je ne m'intéresse pas du tout à la blobitecture,
ou toutes ces bêtises superficielles que vous voyez apparaître comme du design.
Ces choses-là -- ce consumérisme artificiellement induit -- je pense que c'est atroce.
Mon monde est le monde de personnes comme
Amory Lovins, Janine Benyus, James Watson.
Je suis dans ce monde-là, mais je travaille uniquement à l'instinct.
Je ne suis pas un scientifique. J'aurais pu l'être, peut-être,
mais je travaille dans ce monde où je fais confiance à mon instinct.
Je suis un traducteur du 21ème siècle, qui traduit la technologie
en produits que nous utilisons tous les jours et auxquels nous nous connectons esthétiquement et naturellement.
Nous devrions développer des choses --
nous devrions développer un emballage pour les idées qui élèvent les perceptions des gens
et le respect pour ce que nous extrayons de la terre
et traduisons en produits d'usage quotidien.
Par exemple, la bouteille d'eau.
Je vais commencer par ce concept de ce que j'appelle l'ADN.
ADN : Art, Design, Nature. Ce sont les trois éléments qui conditionnent mon monde.
Voici un dessin de Léonard de Vinci,
il y a 500 ans, avant la photographie.
Il montre comment l'observation, la curiosité et l'instinct fonctionnent pour créer un art extraordinaire.
Le design industriel est une forme d'art du 21ème siècle.
Des gens comme Léonard -- il n'y en a pas eu beaucoup --
avaient cette curiosité incroyablement instinctive.
Je travaille dans une posture similaire.
Je ne veux pas paraître prétentieux en disant ça,
mais c'est un dessin que j'ai réalisé sur une tablette numérique il y a deux ou trois ans --
bien après au 21ème siècle, 500 ans plus tard.
C'est mon impression de l'eau.
L'impressionnisme étant la forme d'art la plus précieuse sur cette planète :
100 millions de dollars, au moins, pour un Monet.
J'utilise, maintenant, un tout nouveau processus.
Il y a quelques années, j'ai réinventé mon processus pour suivre des gens comme
Greg Lynn, Tom Main, Zaha Hadid, Rem Koolhaas --
toutes ces personnes que je pense être persévérantes et pionnières
avec de fantastiques nouvelles idées sur comment créer la forme.
Tout ceci est créé numériquement.
Ici vous pouvez voir l'usinage, le fraisage d'un bloc d'acrylique.
C'est ce que je montre au client pour dire "C'est ce que je veux faire."
À ce stade-là, je ne sais pas du tout si c'est possible.
C'est séducteur, mais je sens au plus profond de moi que c'est possible.
Alors on y va. On regarde l'outillage. On regarde comment on le produit.
Ce sont les choses invisibles que vous ne verrez jamais dans votre vie.
C'est le bruit de fond du design industriel.
C'est comme un Anish Kapoor coulant à travers un Richard Serra.
A mes yeux, c'est plus précieux que le résultat. Je n'en ai pas.
Lorsque je gagnerai un peu d'argent, je m'en ferai faire un pour moi.
Voici le produit final. Quand je l'ai reçu, j'ai pensé que j'avais échoué.
Ça ne ressemblait à rien. Ça devait ne ressembler à rien.
Mais quand j'y ai mis de l'eau, j'ai réalisé que j'avais posé une peau sur l'eau elle-même.
C'est une icône de l'eau elle-même,
et ça élève la perception par les gens du design contemporain.
Chaque bouteille est différente : chaque volume d'eau donnera une forme différente.
C'est l'individualisme de masse à partir d'un seul et même produit. Il tient dans la main.
Il tient dans une main arthritique. Il tient dans la main d'un enfant.
La mosaïque rend le produit fort.
C'est un millefiori d'idées.
Dans l'avenir, ils ressembleront à ça, car nous avons besoin de nous éloigner
de ces types de polymères et de les utiliser en tant que matériel médical
ou tant qu'objets plus importants dans la vie.
Les biopolymères, ces nouvelles idées pour les matériaux,
entreront en jeu dans une décennie probablement.
Ça n'a pas l'air aussi cool, non ?
Mais je peux vivre avec. Je n'ai pas de problème.
Je crée pour cette condition, les biopolymères. C'est l'avenir.
J'ai pris cette vidéo au Cap l'an dernier.
C'est le côté bizarre en train d'apparaître.
J'ai un intérêt spécial dans ce type de choses qui m'en mettent plein la vue.
Je ne sais pas s'il faut tomber à genoux ou pleurer.
Je ne sais pas ce que je pense, mais je sais juste que la nature s'améliore
avec un objectif toujours grandissant par rapport au passé,
et cette étrangeté est une conséquence de la pensée innovante.
Quand je regarde tout cela, elles me semblent très normales.
Mais tout ça a évolué depuis des années, et maintenant ce que nous essayons de faire --
J'ai trois semaines pour concevoir un téléphone.
Comment je fais, moi, pour faire un téléphone en trois semaines,
quand tout ça prend des centaines de millions d'années pour évoluer?
Comment pouvez-vous condenser ça?
On en revient à l'instinct.
Je ne parle pas de concevoir des téléphones qui ressemblent à ça,
et je ne cherche pas à concevoir l'architecture comme ça.
Je suis simplement intéressé par les modèles naturels de croissance,
et les belles formes que seule la nature crée vraiment.
Comment ça me transcende et comment ça ressort,
c'est ce que j'essaie de comprendre.
Voici une radio d'un avant-bras humain. C'est ensuite manipulé grâce à
un prototypage rapide pour en révéler la structure cellulaire. J'ai tout ça dans mon bureau.
Mon bureau est un mélange du Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle et d'un laboratoire de la NASA.
C'est un curieux genre d'endroit bizarre.
Voici l'un de mes spécimens.
C'est fait de -- l'os est composé d'un mélange de minéraux inorganiques et de polymères.
J'ai étudié la cuisine pendant quatre ans, et durant cette période,
appelée la science domestique, c'était un peu un truc pas cher
pour que j'essaie d'obtenir une qualification scientifique.
(Rires)
En fait, j'ai mis de la marijuana dans tout ce que j'ai cuisiné -- (Rires)
-- et j'ai eu accès aux plus belles filles. C'était fabuleux.
Tous les gars de l'équipe de rugby ne pouvaient pas comprendre, mais bon --
voici une meringue. C'est un autre de mes échantillons.
Une meringue est faite exactement de la même façon, à mon avis, qu'un os.
Elle est fabriquée à partir de polysaccharides et de protéines.
Si vous versez de l'eau dessus, ça se dissout.
Pourrions-nous fabriquer à partir de produits alimentaires dans le futur?
Ce n'est pas une mauvaise idée. Je ne sais pas. J'ai besoin de parler à Janine
et d'autres personnes à ce sujet, mais je crois instinctivement
que cette meringue peut devenir quelque chose, une voiture -- je ne sais pas.
Je suis également intéressé par les modèles de croissance :
la façon débridée selon laquelle la nature fait pousser les choses pour ne pas être du tout limitée par la forme.
Ces formes interdépendantes, elles inspirent tout ce que je fais
bien que je pourrais finir par faire quelque chose d'incroyablement simple.
Voici un détail d'une chaise que j'ai conçue en magnésium.
Ça montre cette intrication d'éléments et la beauté naturelle de la pensée mélangeant l'ingénierie
et la biologie, représentée à peu près comme une structure osseuse.
N'importe lequel de ces éléments peut être accroché sur un mur comme une sorte d'objet d'art.
C'est la première chaise au monde faite en magnésium.
Ça a coûté 1,7 millions de dollars pour la développer. Elle s'appelle Go chez Bernhardt.
Elle est parue dans Time en 2001
comme le nouveau langage du 21ème siècle.
Bon sang. Pour quelqu'un qui a grandi au Pays de Galles dans un petit village, c'est pas mal.
Ça vous montre comment faire une forme holistique, comme l'industrie automobile,
puis vous prenez ce dont vous avez besoin.
C'est une façon absolument magnifique de travailler.
C'est une façon divine de travailler.
Voici -- c'est organique et c'est essentiel.
C'est un design absolument écrémé, et quand vous le regardez,
vous voyez des êtres humains. A vos souhaits.
Lorsque ça se transforme en polymères, vous pouvez modifier l'élasticité, la fluidité de la forme.
Voici une idée pour une chaise en polymère, par injection de gaz, d'une seule pièce.
La nature creuse des trous dans les choses. Elle libère la forme.
Elle enlève tout ce qui est superflu. C'est ce que je fais.
Je fais des choses organiques qui sont essentielles.
Je ne fais pas -- et elles ont l'air funky aussi -- mais
Je ne cherche pas à faire des choses funky parce que je pense que c'est disgracieux.
Je cherche à regarder les formes naturelles.
Si vous poussez plus loin l'idée de la technologie fractale, prenez une membrane,
qui rétrécit constamment comme la nature le fait :
ça pourrait être un siège pour une chaise,
ça pourrait être une semelle pour une chaussure de sport,
ça pourrait être une voiture incorporée en sièges.
Wouah! Allez, c'est parti. C'est tout ça.
C'est ce qui existe dans la nature. L'observation nous permet maintenant
d'amener au quotidien ce processus naturel dans le processus de design. C'est ce que je fais.
Voici une exposition qui a lieu actuellement à Tokyo.
Ça s’appelle Superliquidity. C'est mon investigation sculpturale.
C'est comme du Henry Moore du 21ème siècle. Quand vous voyez un Henry Moore
vos cheveux se dressent, toujours. Il y a une sorte d'étonnante connexion spirituelle.
S'il était un concepteur de voiture, nous serions tous en train d'en conduire une.
A son époque, il était le plus grand contribuable de Grande-Bretagne.
C'est la puissance du design organique.
Il contribue immensément à notre sens de l'être,
notre sens des relations avec les objets,
notre sensualité et cette espèce de --
même ce côté socio-érotique, qui est très important.
Ceci est mon œuvre. C'est tout mon processus.
Tout ça est en fait vendu comme des œuvres d'art.
Ce sont de très grands tirages. Mais c'est comme ça que je parviens à cet objet.
Ironiquement, cet objet a été fabriqué par le processus de Killarney,
qui est un processus tout nouveau dans ce 21ème siècle,
j'entends Greg Lynn rire aux éclats quand je dis ça.
Je vous en parlerai plus tard.
Quand je regarde ces images de données, je vois des choses nouvelles.
Je suis -- c'est auto-inspiré. Structures diatomiques, radiolaires,
les choses que nous ne pouvions pas voir, mais que nous pouvons faire maintenant.
Celles-ci sont aussi excavées. Elles sont faites virtuellement à partir de rien.
Elles sont fabriqués à partir de silice. Pourquoi pas des structures de voitures comme ça?
Le corail, toutes ces forces naturelles enlèvent ce dont ils n'ont pas besoin
et délivrent la beauté à son maximum.
Nous devons être dans ce domaine. Je veux faire des trucs comme ça.
Il s'agit d'une nouvelle chaise qui devrait être en vente en Septembre.
C'est pour une société italienne, appelée Moroso.
C'est une chaise en polymère par injection de gaz.
Les trous que vous voyez là sont très filtrés,
versions édulcorées de l'extrémité des structures diatomiques.
Ça va avec l'écoulement du polymère et vous verrez --
l'image qui vient maintenant montre la chose entière.
C'est super d'avoir des sociétés en Italie, qui souscrivent à cette façon de rêver.
Si vous voyez les ombres qui passent à travers,
elles sont en fait probablement plus importantes que le produit
mais c'est le minimum qu'il faut.
L'excavation à l'arrière vous permet de respirer.
Elle enlève tout matériau dont vous n'avez pas besoin
et en fait elle assure la flexion aussi, du coup --
J'allais faire quelques pas de danse.
Je suis actuellement en train de travailler dessus.
Je recherche des structures de surface unique et la façon dont elles ondoient --
la façon dont elles ondoient et s'étirent. C'est basé sur des typologies de meubles,
mais ce n'est pas la motivation finale. C'est fabriqué à partir d'aluminum,
par opposition à "aluminium", et il a grandi.
Il a grandi dans mon esprit, et ensuite il a grandi en ce qui concerne
l'ensemble du processus par lequel je passe.
Cela date de deux semaines, c'était à CCP à Coventry, qui construit des pièces pour Bentley.
C'est en train d'être construit au moment où je vous parle,
cela sera présenté à Phillips l'année prochaine à New York.
J'ai une grande exposition avec la maison d'enchères Phillips.
Quand je vois ces animations, doux Jésus, je suis médusé.
C'est ce qui se passe dans mon atelier tous les jours. Je marche -- je voyage. Je reviens.
Quelqu'un a fait ça sur un ordinateur -- il y a eu ce, oh mon Dieu.
Donc j'essaie de créer cette énergie d'invention tous les jours dans mon studio.
Cette espèce de soupe effervescente et chargée de sens qui fournit des idées.
Les structures de surface unique. Les meubles en sont un bon exemple.
Comment vous faites pousser des jambes à une surface.
J'aimerais construire ça un jour. Et peut-être que je le construirais aussi
à partir de farine, de sucre, de polymère, de copeaux de bois --
je ne sais pas, de cheveux humains. Je ne sais pas. J'aimerais m'essayer à ça.
Je ne sais pas. Si j'avais un peu de temps.
Ça c'est le côté bizarre qui ressort encore,
et beaucoup d'entreprises ne comprennent pas ça.
Il y a trois semaines j'étais avec Sony à Tokyo. Ils m'ont dit : "Donnez-nous du rêve."
"Quel est notre rêve ? Comment pouvons-nous battre Apple ?"
J'ai dit : "Eh bien, ne copiez pas Apple, ça c'est sûr."
J'ai dit : "Faites dans les biopolymères." Ils ne m'ont pas cru.
Quel gâchis. Bref. (Rires)
Non, c'est vrai. Je les emmerde. Je les emmerde. Je le pense.
(Rires)
Je donne, ils ne prennent pas. J'ai eu cette image depuis 20 ans.
J'ai eu cette image d'une goutte d'eau depuis 20 ans assis sur un lit chaud.
C'est l'image d'une voiture pour moi.
C'est la voiture de l'avenir. C'est une goutte d'eau.
J'ai passé mon temps à parler et reparler de ça comme pas possible.
Les voitures ont tout faux.
Je vais vous montrer quelque chose d'un peu bizarre maintenant.
Ils ont ri dans le monde entier quand j'ai montré ça.
Le seul endroit où ils n'ont pas ri, c'était à Moscou.
Leurs voitures ont plus de 30 000 composants.
Vous ne trouvez pas ça ridicule ? Ne pourriez-vous pas en faire à partir de 300 ?
Voici un plateau de carbone et nylon, formé sous vide. Tout y est intégré de manière holistique.
Ça s'ouvre et ça se ferme comme une boîte à pain.
Il n'y a pas de moteur. Il y a un panneau solaire à l'arrière,
et des batteries dans les roues.
Elles sont intégrées comme en Formule 1. Vous les décrochez de votre mur.
Vous les branchez dedans. Et le tour est joué.
Une voiture à trois roues : lente, féminine, transparente,
pour que vous puissiez voir les gens à l'intérieur. Vous conduisez différemment.
(Rires)
Vous voyez le truc. Vous le voyez.
Vous le voyez, non pas anesthésié, séparé de la vie.
Il y a un trou à l'avant, et il y a une raison à ça.
C'est une voiture citadine. Vous conduisez. Vous sortez.
Vous conduisez jusqu'à une trompe. Vous sortez. Elle vous élève.
Elle présente le panneau solaire au soleil,
et la nuit c'est un réverbère.
(Applaudissements)
C'est ce qui arrive si vous êtes inspirés par un réverbère d'abord,
puis concevez la voiture par la suite. Ces bulles --
Je vois ces bulles avec ces paquets d'hydrogène,
flottant autour sur le sol, conduites par AI.
Quand j'ai montré ça en Afrique du Sud,
tout le monde disait après ; "Ouais, bon, une voiture sur un bâton. J'aime bien."
Vous imaginez ? Une voiture sur un bâton.
Si vous la mettez à côté d'une architecture contemporaine,
ça me semble totalement naturel.
C'est comme ça que je fais mes meubles.
Je ne mets plus de meubles Charles Eames dans des bâtiments.
Oublions ça. Passons.
J'essaie de construire des meubles qui conviennent à l'architecture.
J'essaie de construire des systèmes de transport.
Je travaille sur des avions pour Airbus, le tout --
Je fais tout ce genre de choses en essayant de forcer ces rêves naturels,
inspirés par la nature. Je vais finir sur deux choses.
Ceci est la stéréolithographie d'un escalier.
C'est un peu une dédicace à James, James Watson.
J'ai construit cette chose pour mon studio.
Ça m'a coûté 250 000 $ pour la construire.
La plupart des gens achètent une Aston Martin avec cette somme. J'ai construit ça.
Voici les données qui vont avec. Incroyablement complexes.
Ça a pris environ deux ans, parce que je recherche un design écrémé.
Des choses fines, efficaces. Des produits sains.
Ceci est construit à partir de composites. C'est un élément unique
qui tourne pour créer un élément holistique,
ça c'est une rampe en fibre de carbone
qui est soutenue à deux endroits seulement.
Les matériaux modernes nous permettent de faire des choses modernes.
Voici une photo en studio.
C'est à peu près à quoi ça ressemble tous les jours.
Il ne faut pas avoir le vertige en y descendant.
Il n'y a pratiquement pas de rampe. Ça ne respecte aucun standard.
(Rires)
Qui s'en soucie ?
Oui, et elle a une rampe interne qui lui donne sa force. C'est cette intégration holistique.
C'est mon studio. Il est souterrain.
C'est dans Notting Hill à côté de toute la fange --
les prostituées, etc.
C'est à côté du studio original de David Hockney.
Il a un système d'éclairage qui change pendant la journée.
Mes gars sortent pour déjeuner. La porte est ouverte. Ils reviennent,
parce qu'il pleut normalement, et ils préfèrent rester à l'intérieur.
C'est mon studio. Un crâne d'éléphant de l'université d'Oxford, 1988.
J'ai acheté ça l'année dernière. Ils sont très difficiles à trouver.
Je voudrais -- si quelqu'un a un squelette de baleine qu'il voudrait me vendre,
je le mettrai dans le studio.
Donc, je vais simplement couper -- intervenir un peu
sur certaines choses que vous verrez dans la vidéo.
C'est une vidéo faite maison; je l'ai faite moi-même à trois heures du matin
juste pour vous montrer mon vrai monde. Vous ne voyez jamais ça.
Vous ne voyez jamais d'architectes ou de designers qui vous montrent leur vrai monde.
Ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une Plasnet. Il s'agit d'un polycarbonate --
une nouvelle chaise en bio-polycarbonate que je fais en Italie.
Le premier vélo en bambou au monde avec un guidon pliable.
On devrait tous rouler sur un vélo de ce genre.
Alors que la Chine achète toutes ces voitures de merde,
nous devrions rouler sur des vélos comme celui-là. En contrepoids.
Comme je le disais, c'est un croisement entre le Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle et
un laboratoire de la NASA. C'est plein de prototypes et d'objets.
Je me répète, il est auto-inspirateur. Je veux dire, les rares fois où j'y suis,
je l'apprécie et je reçois beaucoup d'enfants qui viennent --
beaucoup, beaucoup d'enfants.
Je suis un contaminateur pour tous les enfants de banquiers d'investissement -- enfoirés.
Ce -- désolé -- (Rires)
-- c'est une graine solaire. C'est un concept pour la nouvelle architecture.
Cette chose en haut est la première lampe de jardin à énergie solaire --
la première produite. Giles Revell aurait dû en parler ici aujourd'hui --
superbe photographie de choses que vous ne pouvez pas voir.
Le premier modèle sculptural que j'ai fait pour cette chose à Tokyo.
Beaucoup de choses. Il y a une petite chaise en feuilles -- la petite chose dorée est appelée "Feuille"
C'est en Kevlar.
Sur le mur il y a mon livre intitulé "Supernatural",
qui me permet de me rappeler de ce que j'ai fait, parce que j'oublie.
C'est une brique aérée que j'ai faite à Limoges l'an dernier,
pour le CRAFT (Centre de Recherche des Arts du Feu et de la Terre)
Gayne Obervell, travaillant à trois heures du matin --
je ne paie pas les heures supplémentaires.
Les heures supplémentaires sont la passion du design, alors rejoignez le club ou pas.
Non, c'est vrai. C'est vrai. Des gens comme Tom et Greg --
nous sommes en déplacement permanent -- nous condensons tout là-dedans. Je ne sais pas comment nous le faisons.
La semaine prochaine, je serai à Electrolux en Suède,
puis à Pékin vendredi. Allez comprendre.
Quand je vois des photos d'Ed, je me dis,
pourquoi diable vais-je en Chine ? C'est vrai.
C'est vrai. Parce qu'il y a une âme dans toute cette affaire.
Nous avons besoin d'un nouvel instinct pour le 21ème siècle.
Nous avons besoin de combiner tous ces trucs.
Si tous les gens qui parlent pendant ces conférences
travaillaient sur une voiture ensemble, ce serait une joie, une joie absolue.
Au Japon, je travaille sur un nouveau système de lumière X.
Voici des chaussures touareg d'Afrique du Nord. Ici, un masque Kifwebe.
Voici mes sculptures.
Un moule en gelée de cuivre.
Ça ressemble à un jeu télévisé, n'est-ce pas?
Ça se termine.
Merci, James, pour ta grande inspiration.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)